[Music] a
commencé comme une idée et si nous faisions un
film Deadpool, nous n'étions que quelques-
uns à l'époque et avec le recul, nous n'avions aucune
idée de l'ampleur qu'il deviendrait si innocent
et pourtant l'élan qui avait commencé
Yetta n'était pas vraiment ce que nous avions  à l'esprit
non, cela n'a pas aidé les choses, c'était
plus un qu'il saura pour être honnête et nous avons
finalement cessé de demander,
nous n'avons aucune idée de comment cela s'est passé, mais
je vous promets que je regarde bien
ce que le film a été éclairé en vert je  est allé sur
une énorme cintreuse de coke
donc 2016 c'est un peu flou pour moi, ils
me disent que le film a bien fonctionné bien que 10
ans plus tard, la phase 1 ait dépassé nos
attentes les plus folles, vous savez si vous
m'aviez dit à l'époque qu'un film
engendrerait un vaste - univers cinématographique
J'aurais dit que vous étiez fou mais
nous voici avec de vrais acteurs un
budget d'effets spéciaux modéré et plusieurs
x-men de bas niveau aucun des gros
bien que nous devions économiser quelque chose pour la
phase deux